continues here in downtown las vegas i'm
in front of the easy pawn
this is the store that was broken into
and looted by
demonstrators last night as you can see
crews are now
boarding up the windows and doors and as
crews are doing this something the
community decided to come out here on
sunday as well
to do their part to help the community
heal
it might not be much but it's what we
can do right now
a selfless act cory barnard and her
husband clint graffiti off
property it just felt like this is what
we need to do to come
help the couple visit downtown las vegas
after seeing the vandalism during the
black lives matter protest saturday
night
we're not cleaning up to erase any of
the feelings or the emotions we're just
cleaning up because
we want this city to be beautiful always
a crew boards up the nevada state bank
first floor following destruction of
windows and doors
some also volunteered to remove the
spray paint from the federal building
walls
it's terrifying to see what our world is
coming to
those speaking with me support
protesting the death of george floyd
but not all agree on people choosing
violence to demonstrate
all this that you're doing what is what
is you what did you gain
from it i mean you know i don't see it's
pointless
it's a reflection of what's in the
mental
state people are frustrated and they're
upset
and that's their way of expressing
themselves causing even more concern as
racial tensions flare
we all understand the pain and the hurt
that everybody is going through
scars on the community that bernard and
others attempt to heal
doing my part to help the city that we
love
the quartets hotel and casino on fremont
street was also vandalized
i reached out to the property owners
they do not have a comment
but tell me they do still plan to reopen
this thursday
reporting live near fremont street
kristen drummond 8 news now